how ya got involved if you want me to
drive you we got to go no I want
personal chauffeur go horse okay
seriously dad walking would have been
fine
breaking news spider-man saves the day a
guest spider-man this guy swings in once
the day zip zap zop dancing guys don't
cops run red lights oh yeah some do but
uh not your dad in your universe there's
only one spider-man but there's another
universe it looks it sounds like yours
but it's not my name is Miles Morales
thank you you like me I knew my day
would come around his time I know it's
complicated
want to know what happened to you I can
teach you to be spider-man hmm I love
this burger so delicious
well the best burgers I've ever had you
have money right I'm not very liquid
right now I think you're gonna be a bad
teacher how am I supposed to save the
whole world you can't think about state
in the world you have to think about
saving one person one thing I know for
sure don't do it like me do it like you
[Applause]
[Music]
I see the sparking it's amazing paired
up whatever you choose to do with it
you'll be great
I love you miles no dad dad I love you
got a God just like I thought when did
you teach me that I didn't it's a little
joke the team-building hey guys okay
who are you I'm Gwen Stacy how much body
people are there same as a comic-con
what's
you